so hart so klar haben sie das hier noch
nicht zu hören bekommen wirtschaft sei
deutschland wichtiger gewesen als alles
andere
jedes jahr wiederholen die politiker nie
wieder jetzt sehen wir dass diese worte
nichts wert sind in europa wird ein volk
vernichtet
deutschland habe gezögert als es hätte
entscheiden müssen um putins überfall zu
verhindern und es zöge bis heute
donnerstag im bundestag wolodimir
selensky ruft um hilfe und rechnet ab
lenski hat unbedingt recht meines
erachtens die deutschen haben viele
viele strategische fehler gemacht in der
g ob allein das man nicht geopolitisch
denken wollte stichwort energiepolitik
und es kann natürlich nicht sein dass
wir im jahr acht nach der annexion der
krim immer noch eine bundeswehr haben
die nicht einsatzbereit ist nicht und
das ist eine verantwortung der politik
hat dass er hat auch das moralische
recht das so zu benennen und einig
jahren dem bundestag der regierung die
leviten zu lesen dass allens kies
ukraine leidet auch weil ganze
generationen deutscher politiker nicht
sehen wollten wohin sich putin und
russland entwickelten lange schien das
nicht bequem
der größte grund ist dass wenn wir
wirklich zur kenntnis genommen hätten
was unübersehbar war dann hätte es ja
grundlegende konsequenzen von uns
gefordert und und die sind anstrengend
wir sehen sie jetzt unter dem der um dem
umstand des krieges sind wir dazu bereit
vorher waren wir nicht bereit wir haben
es uns schön gemacht weil die realität
für uns viel anstrengender geworden wäre
wer krieg nicht an sich ablehnt hat
entweder am herzen oder am hirn oder
beides aber wir sind gerade dass die
wehrhaftigkeit unsere demokratien auf
der probe steht
und dass wir
deshalb auch gezwungenermaßen auf
militärische mittel
zurückgreifen müssten
uns selbst und unsere bündnisse unsere
partner staaten zu verteidigen
deutschland verteidigt vor allem mit
sanktionen gegen russland und putins
umfeld doch inzwischen auch mit
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine zur
kriegspartei wird es dadurch nicht doch
selbst militärisches eingreifen diese
das völkerrecht wohl zu wenn
festgestellt ist dass der andere staat
der bessere staat gewalt anwende für
geräte die eine aggression speed
betreibt dann ist eigentlich die
gesamten die alle mitgliedsstaaten der
un dazu aufgerufen dagegen vorzugehen
also rein juristisch gesehen ein
völkerrecht ich wäre auch eine stärkere
militärische intervention
zulässig politisch unklug meines
erachtens aber sie wäre völkerrechtlich
gedeckt ich habe den eindruck dass
dieses argument dass wenn man das macht
dann sind wir kriegspartei und dann ist
der weltkrieg
unausweichlich ich glaube dass das nicht
ganz stimmt
putins überfall auf die ukraine gilt
nicht nur der ukraine und niemand weiß
wie weit er macht habe im kreml geht der
westen muss sich auch vieles einstellen
kurzfristig müssen wir alles tun dass
putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnt wenn er
ihn gewinnt dann haben wir ein anderes
europa dann hat sich krieg als mittel
der politik bewährt das müssen wir
verhindern und ich glaube darum geht es
jetzt dass wir die sicherheitspolitische
wende nicht einfach zu reden sondern
dass wir wirklich taten folgen lassen
daran müssen wir stolz auf messen und
jetzt geht es darum einen möglichen
nächsten schritt putin vorzubeugen also
die bedrohung polens und des baltikums
zwölf minuten spricht zielinski der
kanzler an diesem tag 100 tage im amt
scholz applaudiert und zwei mal hätte in
diesem moment mehr erwarten dürfen
[Applaus]